Fox News has gone to Tucker Carlson's
home studio and they've picked up their
equipment and they have taken it away
you know the truth is it's not rare or
surprising that if a network builds you
a studio and they put in their equipment
if you no longer work for them they're
going to come back and take the
equipment it's actually not a crazy
thing the Optics of Tucker Carlson in
Maine with an ax and the idea that he's
up there thinking of how to launch his
Twitter show and fox sends people to
just strip reportedly they even took
down the temporary walls they built sort
of like faux walls fake walls inside his
his house to make it look like a room of
some kind they took everything it is
funny and one of the people that's
working with Tucker said we they really
took everything down to the studs we're
going to need to put the walls back up
Tucker will come back